congratulations on the film you both are
so good in this I was just curious about
Ben Affleck and his directing style
because I love his character film night
when he gives these motivational
speeches I was giggling a lot did Ben
ever do those as a director on set with
you too oh painful absolutely painful
every morning we got to come in we gotta
hold hands
yeah he drops this big American flag
behind him like Patton it's uh it's
tough yeah uh but uh the money was right
and we so we just got through it yeah
on this okay so how did you get pitched
on this movie
why'd you want to sign on yeah I mean it
was really just kind of uh Matt and Ben
are calling are you uh up for it and
it's like yes please
um oh what's the script what's the story
didn't really matter it was more about
uh that they were organizing a a really
cool group of people in front of him
behind the camera and it's you know it's
that invite to the party or like oh yeah
I'm gonna clear everything out and make
sure I'm there
exactly similar
read it I was I was happy to be invited
so it was it's a great bunch of people
you know you look every day you'd look
around and I'd see Jason or Viola Chris
Tucker Matt and Ben and just be like how
the hell did I get here with these cats
this movie oh this movie's so good for
so many reasons but I also just love
listening to the 80s Tunes like I loved
all the music do you guys have a pump up
song like a lot of athletes do or sports
teams
his ringtones eye of the tiger eye the
tiger so you call him you're gonna hear
that yeah
um do some push-ups uh I mostly sort of
Spandau Ballet I like to keep it kind of
mellow
um but uh yeah that was an incredible
unfortunately there won't be a
soundtrack because the soundtrack you
don't have soundtracks anymore but um
it's really cool to go down memory lane
with uh all those songs he pulled
I'm the tiger Chris I'm impressed yeah I
need help I need all the help I can get
so that really gets me going you put on
your leg warmers and your headbands yeah
you go and you get after it yeah then
put on the Jane Fonda workout huh go for
it that's a classic yeah
um are any of you guys obsessed with
sneakers who do you think has the most
expensive sneaker collection out of this
cast
we're both too dorky dad
you don't want to say yes in some new
kids shoes We're trying to take care of
our like bunions now and you're right
now if they make an Air Jordan in sort
of like a washed leather
um
um uh but you know it's uh it's not
pretty not great no
it once it was it once was for me right
it once was I really tried but I I I've
fallen off
okay got you and you're just blaming age
at this point yeah yeah last time I had
a pair of high tops it was a it was the
pump you know the the Reebok Pump that's
that's how old I am so uh you know it's
just uh actor boots now and um slippers
a lot of slippers I'm in my slippers by
4 30 every day yeah that's nice
like
um
like on set all the time are you guys
joking around a lot lots of bits lots
too many too many too many bits I'm
trying to work hard here I'm trying to
do something you know and Jason's
usually in the way of that
you know yeah do you guys wish you had
more scenes together I do he doesn't
yeah he does it yeah no it would have
been pretty good you know Chris has got
some real game
um now you know I was working a lot with
Matt who's not too bad himself but uh
you know I was just howling uh we're you
know we were screening the other day and
his stuff is just you miss half of his
dialogue because the whole theater is
laughing so much so uh I gotta I'm
looking forward to watching it a few
more times
I love those phone calls they're so good
how much of that was ad-libbed uh not a
lot of it the script was pretty great
you know that's cool yeah you just kind
of followed that and uh he's being nice
to the writer he he uh he he plused it
quite a bit
I like to smile uh and last question to
wrap up Jason uh what surprised you
about working with Matt especially in
this role when you're doing your scenes
together because they're so good I did I
didn't know he was bald you know he's
got some of the best wigs in the
business that was a real shocker to me
um the uh the body I always knew was
there he likes to play with his weight
now but the hair that was uh that was a
big one
um but bless him uh he's got good pieces
amazing guys thanks so much congrats on
the movie nice to meet you